you
[Music]
I
grew up watching these monster movies
when I was a little kid I remember being
utterly terrified there is something
about those first horror movies Alex
wants to give them proper honor we owe
the audience a monster movie
[Applause]
[Music]
great so one go the key for us was to
tell a story that felt real our picture
takes place in modern day
what's interesting about the way these
stories are told is you identify with
these classic characters they terrify us
and yet you feel sympathy for them
welcome to Buddhism
this sensor magnificent they're
beautiful they're hunting the world will
feel enormous oh
we shot a huge action sequence here in
the heart of Africa
we're done zero gravity inside a real
plane
it's so good
you can do
annabelle wallis is great he's never
even touched us before it she's doing
this the cast they're so talented you
have Russell Crowe Jake Johnson these
guys that are fun to look with Russell
have known each other over 20 years
we've talked about working together now
we're gonna do this very cool fight
Sofia to tell it brings a true humanity
to the mummy even when she's doing
horrifying things
the audience can expect to be
excruciating leak terrified Tom said
this is bigger than anything I've ever
done before it's like being on a
rollercoaster ride that's what this film
is gonna deliver it's gonna keep your
right in the edge of your seat you're
not gonna want to take your eyes off the
screen
it's a hell of a lot fun
[Music]